directed by christopher nolan
interstellar is a fantastic tale of time
space and love but if you got a bit lost
in the final act of the film we wouldn't
blame you so let's do our best to walk
through the bizarre mind-bending ending
of
interstellar life on earth isn't great
in interstellar massive dust storms are
tearing up the planet crops are failing
and soon humanity will cease to exist
looking for answers nasa turns to the
skies hoping for some kind of insight
okay
now you need to tell me what your plan
is to save the world
as we learn at the beginning of the film
a group of 12 scientists traveled
through a mysterious wormhole that
appeared near saturn to see if the 12
planets on the other side could sustain
human life a few years later the
endurance and its crew including matthew
mcconaughey's cooper and anne hathaway's
brand are going to visit the three most
promising planets in the hopes of
colonizing one when they arrive on dr
man's planet the heroic scientist
assures them this icy cold spot is the
perfect place for humans to live
our world
is cold
stark
but undeniably beautiful
unfortunately it's soon all revealed to
be a ruse although each of the original
12 scientists knew their trip was one
way man admits he never fully considered
the possibility that his planet would be
uninhabitable and that he might die
alone although he resisted the urge for
years he eventually falsified his survey
data to coax another team to travel to
his planet intending to use the
endurance to escape at this point man is
so desperate to leave that he'll do
anything even kill paranoid that the
endurance crew won't go along with his
plan once they learn what he's done man
attempts to kill cooper so he can make
his getaway
back on earth cooper's now grown
children find themselves at odds his
daughter murph played by jessica
chastain has realized the surface of our
planet has become uninhabitable so
naturally she's trying to persuade her
brother tom to bring his family to the
secret nasa facility where she's been
working on the gravitational equation
that would allow humanity to escape into
space and mass but despite murph's
warnings tom refuses to abandon the
farmhouse where they grew up after
cooper left them in their grandfather's
care when they were children never to be
heard from again tom lost all faith in
nasa's ability to help them
that didn't raise you to be this dumb
tom dad didn't raise me grandpa did he's
buried out back with mom and jesse
convinced her brother is making a
terrible mistake murph sets fire to
tom's cornfields knowing that since tom
relies on his crops for survival he'll
be forced to drive out to try to
extinguish the blaze that buys murph
enough time to return to the house and
evacuate tom's wife and son likely in
the hopes that once tom realizes his
family has gone to the nasa facility
he'll have no choice but to join them
hey desperate times call for desperate
measures
without enough fuel to either return to
earth or travel to the third potentially
habitable planet cooper proposes to use
the gravity of the black hole gargantua
to execute a slingshot maneuver which
would send the endurance off with enough
inertia to reach the planet dr edmunds
would send to assess however every time
the endurance crew approaches the black
hole its gravitational field distorts
their perception of time due to
relativity meaning what they experience
is only minutes passes as years for
anyone outside gargantua's gravity every
hour we spend on that planet will be
seven years back on earth
by executing cooper's slingshot maneuver
he and brand will experience time
slippage of 51 years they both realize
this means cooper will have to give up
hope of ever seeing his children back on
earth as they will likely have died of
old age by the time the endurance exits
gargantua's gravity still cooper knows
that his plan is humanity's last chance
for survival adding even more drama to
cooper's decision is man's earlier
speech about the moment humans
experience before death according to man
as our brains grasp at survival we'll
experience a vision of the thing we most
desire to see again man speculates that
cooper's final image will be of his
children since they're his reason for
living at the moment of death your
mind's gonna push a little bit harder to
survive
for them
by giving up hopes of seeing his
children again cooper is prioritizing
the future of humanity over his own
motivations for survival
with its depleted fuel supplies
endurance must decrease its weight to
pull free of gargantua's gravity after
completing cooper's slingshot maneuver
before beginning the maneuver cooper
decides the shuttle holding tars will
detach and drop into the black hole in
addition to relieving the endurance of
the shuttle's weight cooper hopes that
tars can collect the quantum data from
inside the singularity that nasa
scientists on earth need to complete the
gravitational equation that will allow
humanity to leave while odds are slim
that tars will be able to transmit this
data back to earth cooper is determined
to at least try since it's his
children's last hope of survival however
cooper doesn't tell brand that losing
tar's shuttle won't account for a big
enough drop in weight in fact an
additional shuttle has to detach in
order for the endurance to escape cooper
decides that he should bite the
proverbial bullet leaving bran to
continue on to edmund's planet and
restart the human race he doesn't tell
brand until the last moment because he
knows she would argue with his decision
but even without the possibility of
seeing his children again cooper is at
peace with his probable death
after falling into the black hole cooper
continues to record what he's seeing and
transmits it back to tars hoping the
additional data might help scientists
back on earth although he expects to
eventually get crushed by gargantua's
gravity cooper is miraculously spared
once his shuttle is ripped apart and
that's when things get crazy after
surviving the wild ride cooper gets
transported to an infinite
interdimensional library that allows him
to look back into different moments in
his daughter's childhood bedroom
including the day he left for his
mission on the endurance
if you're leaving just go
no
don't go don't go you idiot
tarz determines that they made it
through gargantua alive because they
were protected by them the mysterious
beings who constructed the wormhole in
the first place since the beginning of
the film who they are has been a mystery
while nasa realized the wormhole was
artificially constructed by some sort of
advanced intelligent beings they didn't
have any information about them beyond
the assumption that they must be
benevolent
tarz deduces they also must have built
this library to help cooper understand
their five-dimensional reality and sure
it's confusing but it's also nice to
have other worldly beings on your side
although the library where they bring
cooper seems to go on forever every part
of this room serves as a window into the
exact same place his daughter murph's
childhood bedroom at first cooper seems
to think he's been brought to her
because of his own desire to see her
again but tarz helps him understand they
have constructed this three-dimensional
reality for cooper allowing him to
access all five dimensions in a way he
can understand why they want to help us
huh i don't know but they constructed
this three-dimensional space inside
their five-dimensional reality to allow
you to understand it
together tarz and cooper figure out that
through the library cooper is able to
physically influence different points in
space-time by using gravity to move
things as time and gravity are the
fourth and fifth dimensions that exist
in their reality but what's the point of
all this cooper deduces that he's been
brought here to send a message back
through time using gravity and that
murph has to be the one to receive it
cooper realizes that while he thought
they were fixated on him he's not
actually the one who's most important to
saving humanity murph is the library
exists to ensure that cooper will be
able to deliver his daughter the
information she needs right when she
needs it
after cooper finds himself stuck in the
library he realizes he's supposed to
pass along the quantum data that tarz
collected from inside gargantua the
information the robot gathered from
inside the black hole will help murph
save mankind and cooper is the
interdimensional messenger selected by
the same mysterious forces that
constructed this library and created the
wormhole near saturn
but something sent you here they chose
you
or who's they
and once cooper understands his new
purpose he realizes the creatures who've
been assisting humanity aren't
extraterrestrial at all
they didn't bring us here at
all brought ourselves
as it turns out at some point in the
future humanity will advance to a place
where we can navigate through all five
dimensions it's these future humans who
used gravity to create the wormhole that
allowed nasa to send scientists to
explore the 12 planets in the first
place these future humans are also the
ones who protected cooper from the
effects of gargantua just as cooper is
able to use the library to influence
events that for him already happened the
humans of the future have been using
their understanding of time and gravity
to ensure their own survival by
assisting cooper murph nasa and the
other humans of their past
after realizing why the library exists
and that they want cooper to give murph
the quantum data she needs to save the
world tarz asks how cooper plans to
communicate such complex information
from another dimension i love tar's love
it's just like grand said my connection
with murph it is quantifiable it's the
key
the robot doesn't understand but cooper
explains that he can trust his love for
his daughter to guide him to exactly
where he needs to be as brand explained
earlier in the film love is the only
thing that transcends all dimensions
including time and space cooper decides
to code the quantum data into the second
hand of the watch he gave murph before
he left assuring tars that she will one
day return for it when tarz asks how
cooper can be sure he responds
because i gave it to her
he's confident that her love for him
will lead her to where she needs to go
just as his love led him back to her
sure enough as all this is happening the
adult murph has indeed returned to her
childhood bedroom drawn by an unseen
force she suddenly understands the ghost
from earlier in the film the entity
trying to contact her with dust patterns
on her bedroom floor was actually her
father reminded of her love for him she
finds the watch and voila things are
suddenly starting to look up for
humanity
with the planet dying humans have to
evacuate the place fast but to solve the
gravitational equation that allows
humanity to escape from the tethers of
earth you need quantum data gathered
from inside a black hole the equation
couldn't reconcile relativity with
quantum mechanics you need more more
more what more data you need to see into
a black hole
thinking that collecting such data is
impossible murph believes the people of
earth are doomed and that her father has
abandoned her however once she realizes
that cooper was her childhood ghost and
that he's given her the data she needs
through the watch she's able to solve
the equation ensuring humanity's
survival once cooper passes along the
quantum data the library tesseract
begins to collapse having served its
purpose cooper loses consciousness and
he later wakes up on a space habitat
orbiting saturn just as they brought
cooper to a library and allowed him to
communicate with his daughter and save
humanity they also brought him back to
safety once he was finished with his
mission only instead of earth he's now
on a gigantic colony floating through
space
thanks to merv's calculations and the
data acquired from the black hole humans
were finally able to leave earth and
mass and now they're spread out over
several different space habitats and
it's all thanks to those mysterious
forces who helped cooper in the library
and made sure people would find him once
it was time for the library to close
due to the time slippage that bran
warned about before executing the
slingshot maneuver around gargantua at
least 51 years have passed for the
people of earth but it's only been hours
for cooper by the time he makes it to
the space habitat known as cooper
station his daughter murph whom he last
saw as a little girl is an old woman on
the verge of death on the flip side
cooper appears to be about the same age
as he was when he left while cooper is
overjoyed to finally be reunited with
his daughter murph knows that she won't
live much longer and tells him that he
should go so that he doesn't have to
watch her die
no parent should have to watch their own
child die
cooper takes his daughter's advice and
steals a ship intending to head back
through the wormhole and join brand on
edmond's planet like cooper she would
have only recently arrived and she'll
soon be entering hypersleep keeping her
the same age until he reaches her sadly
edmunds himself has died at some point
during the decades he spent waiting for
nasa to send a team to his planet but
his brand takes off her helmet and
breathes in the air of her new home at
his grave site it's evident this is the
planet the astronauts have been
searching for where humanity can rebuild
and eventually thrive again check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]